hello there and welcome again we are
broadcasting from the Largo theater in
Los Angeles and here's how we're doing
the shows as I said I have just a
skeleton crew very few people here
everyone's been tested
everyone's socially distance and the
audience is empty except for my trusty
assistant Sona love seccion how you
doing there Sona yesterday was our first
show from the Largo how do you think it
went great it's just as good as having
200 people here laughing it's pretty
much the same thing don't you think so
des yeah anyway these are strange times
as you can see Stone is wearing a mask
it's probably why you can't hear her
laughter and her cheering I wear a mask
all the time except when I'm
broadcasting everyone here is wearing a
mask and that's what's strange though is
that that's that should be what
everyone's doing
everyone should be wearing a mask but as
coronavirus case has continued to spike
states are really struggling to get
people to wear face masks in public you
know we've already seen companies
selling mask with personalized logos
that's happening well here's the latest
now state governments are getting in the
game by issuing exclusive vanity masks
yeah these are one-of-a-kind masks with
a personalized message just like vanity
license plates yeah this is true here
are some I saw today here's one I've had
sex strange odd good for you I guess
look at this one beef breath not
bragging I don't think look at this one
creepy adult pacifier on other side
probably good to know yeah here's this
one is this right the answer is no that
is not right check out this one warning
eye
have soul patch I don't know why it's
not a complete sentence it could have
been I have a soul patch
what are you the Hulk either way no one
wants to know and finally here's a mask
I think it's terrific mask matches the
carpet I've had some success with that
one I don't even know what I mean by
success